[Standing on a busy street corner, a man lights up a cigarette.]
[Narrator:] The habit of smoking is just a
part of everyday life.
[Head shots of people on the street puffing on cigarettes as they go about their lives.]
[A teenage boy is shown smoking, then two more men, then a grinning fellow with a cigarette tucked in his mouth.]
[Narrator:] These people really believe that
cigarettes mean something to them.
[Saxophone plays in the background as more smokers are shown.]
[Music peters out as man smoking a cigarette makes a disgusted face.]
[Narrator:] The cigarette is a tube of paper filled with loosely packed, chopped-up tobacco
which burns slowly given the proper draft.
In many ways it can be compared with a chimney.
When a chimney smokes badly, it means that the fuel in the fire is only being partially burnt.
And all kinds of gases, dirt, and steam are
spreading into the air.
No one would think of deliberately inhaling the thick smoke from this stack.
The soot and gas would soon choke one to death.
Yet a cigarette is also a chimney, and the
pleasure it seems to give people hides
the very real danger it holds for the lungs.
[A man smokes his cigarette with a slight
gasp for breath as he exhales the smoke.]
[Narrator:] The human lungs are a delicate
mechanism
and they can't be easily repaired if they get damaged.
On the inside of the breathing tubes are very small hairs
which are like eyelashes and are in constant movement.
[A diagram of the lungs is shown with the
tiny hairs being blown back and forth.]
[Narrator:] On these, a layer of sticky substance called mucus falls.
Which is constantly being moved up the breathing tube as if on a moving staircase.
In the normal way, small bits of dirt which enter the throat
stick to this layer and are removed upwards. This is the lungs' defense against dirt.
[A larger diagram appears showing both lungs.]
[Narrator:] A smoker however, sucks in dust, smoke, and all kinds of dirt.
[A man is shown smoking back-to-back cigarettes.]
[Narrator:] Only a fraction of which is breathed out again.
[The man exhales the smoke and makes another gasping sound.]
[Narrator:] The smoke inhaled temporarily
paralyzes the little hairs inside the throat.
So that there is no moving escalator to protect the lung against dirt.
Smoke also irritates and causes more liquid mucus to form.
[Narrator:] Since it cannot be removed upwards, it falls back into the lungs.
And if it stays there long, there's a danger of it plugging up some of the smaller tubes.
Infection grows in these warm places,
and a cough on top of trapped air works like bursting a paper bag.
[Man coughs]
[Narrator:] If much of this goes on, the damage done becomes really dangerous.
The victim becomes permanently breathless.
And then, ill.
[The lungs are shown with widespread damage due to cigarette smoke.]
[Narrator:] A healthy lung looks like this.
A more or less regular fine mesh of tissues.
But much of the delicate structure of this
lung has been destroyed by smoking.
[A damaged lung is shown in fine detail.]
[Narrator:] A man with a lung like this is
permanently breathless.
And often too ill to get about at all.
[An elderly man is lying in bed wheezing for breath.]
[Narrator:] This man use to be a heavy smoker. Now he's a helpless invalid.
[Man continues to gasp for air.]
[Doctor:] I just want you to step up and down on these steps Mr. Major, as I tell you.
Right. Come up, up there. Why can't you. That's right. Down the other side. Turn around.
[Mr. Major walks up a step and then down the other side where he turns around to do it all over again.]
[Narrator:] Two years ago this man could swim with his teenage son. But now he can't.
[Doctor:] Now would you like to sit down now?
[Mr. Major:] Sure.
[Doctor:] Is that about as much as you can
do?
[Mr. Major:] [Gasping for breath] That's all,
please, I can't do anymore.
[Narrator:] No one has to tell his son not
to smoke.
[A hand is shown lighting cigarettes attached to individual containers lined up in a row.]
[Narrator:] This is a smoking machine which was specially invented to imitate the way a person smokes.
And to collect scientifically the tobacco
smoke which goes into the body.
[Cigarettes burn into the smoking machine;
an inhaling sound is heard.]
[Narrator:] The throat of the mechanical smoker is a glass tube. And the lungs, a glass bottle.
And it smokes like six people in a row.
[Inhaling and exhaling sounds.]
Every puff is counted.
[Narrator:] After being given only a packet
of only ten each, their throats are stained with tar.
[The doctor examines the tar buildup.]
[Narrator:] Even this small amount can be
taken away and analyzed.
And if the mechanical smoker goes on long enough,
you can soon fill jars with cigarette tar.
[A jar full of hot tar is shown beside an
ashtray filled with cigarette butts.]
[Narrator:] A week, a month, a year, five
years of smoking twenty a day would fill these jars.
This enormous beaker would be filled after
twenty a day for twenty years.
Of course not all this stays in the body.
But part of it does.
Scientists examined this tar and found many complicated chemicals in it.
Though smoking is not the only cause of lung
cancer, it is the major one.
And at least sixteen of these
chemicals are already known to produce cancer.
Research is still going on to find out how
these work in smokers.
It's taking a long time because one can't experiment on live people.
[A teenage boy stands shirtless as a doctor prepares to examine him.]
[Narrator:] As a result of what scientists
have discovered and doctors know,
it's difficult now to find a chest doctor in this country who is still smoking cigarettes.
And here's another reason.
Imagine these two orange blocks as representing in tens of millions all the cigarettes smoked in 1910.
Here are the amounts which have been smoked since then up to 1960.
[Stacks of orange blocks appear behind a year
to represent the number of cigarettes smoked.]
[Narrator:] Compare this to the numbers of
deaths from lung cancer during the same years.
They're in thousands but still going up and
closely following the rising cigarette sales.
Though not everyone who smokes gets lung cancer,
no one knows who will.
[Black blocks are stacked in front of
the orange blocks to represent the number of lung cancer-related death in those years.
[Narrator:] Lung cancer is an increasing menace. Why? Because people are encouraging it by smoking.
[Doctor Two:] There's no mistake about this
[?]. Cigarettes can kill,
and if they don't kill they can rot the lungs.
In this bottle is the lung of a man who was
a moderate smoker
'til this great cancer grew in his lung and killed him.
[The doctor points to a lung with a large tumor in a specimen jar.]
[Doctor Two:] If this man had known what cigarettes were going to do to his lungs,
he wouldn't have smoked. You do know.
[Narrator:] When one is young and feeling
fit one thinks the body can look after itself.
Even when one realizes that smoking can lead to chronic bronchitis
or heart disease as well as lung cancer, it's
a habit which is very difficult to give up.
[A teenage girl is shown smoking, looking at herself in a mirror.]
[Narrator:] These boys and girls may think
it's clever or grown-up to be seen with a cigarette,
but they don't realize that for every day
they smoke they could actually be shortening their own lives.
[Young people and children are seen casually smoking.]
[Narrator:] Smoking in public may seem daring, but it's hardly glamorous.
[A group of women sit in their train car smoking and putting on make-up.]
[Narrator:] This side of smoking is never
shown in advertising.
[A man is shown smoking, but grimacing and looking as if it is distasteful.]
[A man leans over an object he appears to
be repairing, a cigarette dangling from his mouth.]
[A man puts out his cigarette on a
plate with the remains of his breakfast eggs.]
[A cigarette butt is left inside someone's
teacup.]
[Doctor Two:] If you do smoke, well, stop
it. But it's much easier not to start then to stop.
Don't think you can't stop. I used to say
that, but then I saw the damage that cigarettes
were doing to my patients...and I stopped.
If you don't smoke you will save hundreds
of wasted pounds and you'll stay fit.
[Doctor listens to the same teenage boy's chest again.]
[Doctor:] Now breathe deeply.
[The boy is heard breathing in and out, deeply.]
[Narrator:] People with healthy lungs can
really enjoy life.
[A man with healthy lungs goes swimming deep
underwater.]
[A man plays a saxophone beautifully.]
[Two men play-fight underwater.]
[Saxophonist plays.]
[Narrator:] But for people who are smokers,
it's a different story.
[A man is shown rolling a cigarette, and Mr. Majors is seen again, grimacing.]
[Damaged lung tissue is displayed.]
[The man lying in a hospital bed gasping for air is shown.]
[A man coughs.]
[The orange and black blocks representing smokers and cancer deaths flash by.]
[A specimen jar containing portions of  damaged lung is shown.]
[The ashtray and jar of tar is shown filled
to the top.]
[Gasping, labored breathing sounds.]